crab feast you know what it's all about
this is the crab feast I'm yelling [ __ ]
that you ain't gotta ask me cuz you
could trust that every Tuesday you
already know though soccer star JUCO
above-ground cool goes better than most
Jay Larson self-diagnose go down low
this week last week here we go again
crab feast
Oh
oh yeah yeah
almost blacked out welcome back to the
crab feast y'all know Tuesday nothing
[ __ ] crappy for that ask God mmm that
was some pitch touching could have kept
that I felt like I could've kept going
but if BOM was blacked out so maybe I
couldn't kept long no to see it all back
that's all we need sickle cell pull them
back good to be here man Jay Larson here
Jay Larson commie comm Jay Larson comedy
and all social media if we're gonna get
to some thank yous for everybody we saw
so far on the road a a big announcement
I like to make to you guys November 29th
that's a Tuesday
it's literally four weeks away I'm gonna
record an hour special at the El Rey
theater it's gonna be TV taping
I'm funding it myself putting all my
putting the college funds on the line to
shoot without special we got a great
crew that's gonna be this November 29th
there's gonna be two taping 7:30 and
9:30 Los Angeles talking to Los Angeles
Pacific Los Angeles come out and stand
over one that's within two hours I would
love to have you I'm gonna do comp for
all crab fees fans
clearly I want you guys in the audience
is your energy is amazing it's a really
big deal for me the big risk you know I
don't know what can happen with this
thing but I've been telling people you
know if I want other people to invest in
me what better way to prove it to them
by putting my own money up so November
29th 7:30 and 9:30 I have a link on my
website Jay Larson calm be calm go to
that link and just put in I have a code
Larsen for all crab fees fans you get
comp tickets and put you up front of the
taping whatever you want
those are my VIPs so November 29th
recording an hour special to El Rey
theater I'm super excited about it I'm
really proud of the work that I put into
it and I hope you guys can make it out
and make sure you get your new CD yep
and you know the CDs out there I know
I'm trust me you can pick up human math
let it do to human math here that's lady
if you're in LA hold off on the human
map that's all right you know hold off
for a little while and just be there at
the show because I really need people
there that you
know what we're all about and what my
commie is all about and just want to
have family in the audience and your
family everyone else from the country go
pick up you in the math and I mean rye
sickle is here so I want to introduce
you and you do your thing but we want to
say thank you about our tour which will
do Ryan Sickler what's up there oh hey
man thanks for having Ryan slick on
Twitter and Instagram Ryan Sickler
official thanks for making me look for a
jail Facebook Ryan Sickler calm and as
Jay Larson said we've been having so
much fun with you guys Thank You San
Francisco Thank You Sacramento thank you
this is why I was because I could have
said thank you but now it's is you
saying thank you said Ryan do it yeah no
I'm saying hey you know if I just gotta
have some thank you together are you
gonna introduce me go yeah thank you
thank you shot down two sold-out shows
in Chicago and st. Louis thanks a lot
you drunk [ __ ] man the Midwest kids guys
are a lot of fun special thanks to Nikki
Glaser Tim Convy Sean Flannery for
helping the south all those shows you
guys are fantastic second leg coming up
November 5th Asheville North Carolina
Asheville Carolina come see us we got it
we weren't even coming to Asheville and
we got an email saying hey there's
enough interest down here to have you
guys come down and we were like
absolutely if you're in the area make it
a weekend at that town is sick fantastic
come out to Asheville laughs Boston on
the 6 see his own Sunday actually
Asheville is this Saturday coming it's
right there I know Boston on Sunday
Boston if you don't have tickets yet you
might want to get on it because there's
a limited amount left so call over and
get them Caroline's New York November
8th Election Day election that's gonna
be a big day because you're gonna come
into the show laugh your ass off exactly
and when you leave the show there's
gonna be a new president United States
that's the truth so don't forget to vote
get there and then just let go turn your
phone's off we'll have a blast and at
the end of show we'll all look together
and be like who's the President of the
United States a great call it's gonna be
a fun show already said
November night helium Philadelphia can't
wait to come see if Philly Philly come
out if you guys need a ride hop on the
back of the bikes of the wheels of Seoul
and get on out the helium in
Philadelphia November night November
10th Washington dasi girafft house
comedy come on out nation's capital
we're coming to see it's that these are
all one-nighters these are all
one-nighters that's it one time only
1111 Baltimore special day creative
alliance coming out to Patterson Park
Baltimore a lot of great comics have
already come through there it's gonna be
a great show and tickets are going fast
for that show too so you better get on
them if you haven't gotten them and then
November 19th Denver Colorado Saturday
night coming out to the Mile High City
can't wait get your tickets now all
information is up and also actually I'm
on my link for this is not happening I
was fortunate enough to do Ari Shaffir
show Thank You Ari Shaffir on Comedy
Central so one of my favorite stories
you tell brother thanks man
I'll never tell it again 11 that comes
out on November 3rd go give me some love
online make me look good because you
know other people are out there gonna be
trying to beat us up sometimes counting
on you oughta make me look good out
there tickets for all shows you know
they're all going home they're being
like [ __ ] 5 stars and people I'm like
wow he's getting a lot of negative room
that's what I want out there hit it they
don't get it tickets for all shows are
available in Ryan Sickler calm and the
crab feast calm also huge thank you to
all you who purchased merch doing breast
cancer awareness month and our
merchandise makes great holiday gifts as
well you might as well get on it now
Amazon start your holiday shopping now
it's already November it scares the hell
out it's already November please news
are you guys like us we need to ship to
family so Amazon is exactly where you go
that's it please use our link and thank
you to those of you who already do it's
a huge huge help to us all Premium
episodes including Bridgetown and the
new LA pod fest episode are available
for iTunes and nineteen users click on
the premium EPS on the website it's all
there
Facebook Fanpage get over there if
you're in any of those cities are near
any of those cities we just mentioned
for the tour you can get all the tour
information on our Facebook fan page
thank you for the iTunes reviews so many
of those things are what keep this a
free podcast and gives us the chance
that keep the studio that we have to
record and have guests in here and do
all things we do
helps us keep a free podcast free that's
what we do and we can't do it without
the help of you guys and this week's
sponsor MVM T watches that's movement
but goes by MV MT on the symbol gray
watch company was founded on the belief
that style shouldn't break the bank it
was just two college kids in Santa
Barbara who wanted dope watches but
couldn't afford it so they were like hey
let's change the way consumers think
about fashion by offering high-quality
minimalist products at revolutionary
prices they sold over 500,000 watches to
customers in a hundred and sixty
countries around the world
they're great we both got and I love
mine we're at all-time rise got each of
some of that getting mine fit getting
his fit mine came fit mines gold I love
it I think it's dope it's different
you're straight out of the box fit out
of the box about that man um for me it's
like I love the idea of having I like to
match watches to outfits that I wear you
know I mean and the gold is like it's
like a bling one then it's dope and
that's the whole deal with these watches
when you go to get like a quality watch
it's over $500 but movement wants to
start at $95 same quality department
store look and feel but they cut out the
consumer look just going right to you it
looks like let's just say the expensive
competition it really does that feel is
good it will it's it's so well done and
they figured up by selling directly
online they're able to cut up the
middleman and retail markup so everyone
you know they're gonna markup anytime
this summer because everyone needs to
get on it here's the deal get 15% off
today with free shipping and free
returns that's fast I mean I love it
come on going to em VMT watches dot-com
/ Krab CRA B that's MV MT watches
dot-com / crap watch has a really clean
design and seriously been getting
compliments ever since I've been wearing
it I'm sure you have as well I love it
head over to M BMT watches comm / Krab
join the movement today we're excited to
have the movement the crab feast
movement right here well I'll take that
for you movement right here today moment
right here excited to have her on the
podcast so many people recommend it oh
she's got a great podcast herself
we're excited please give a warm welcome
first time on the craft fees
miss Karen Kilgore
thank you every single one of you oh
that's so sweet
I'm smiling already thank you so much
for being here absolutely we're super
stoked to have you and before we begin
will you please plug promote anything
you like your social media your podcast
everything let's see I have two podcasts
I have just one please okay pick one
which one's your favorite I've my
favorite murder which is on feral audio
yeah and then do you need a ride with
Chris Fairbanks are you guys still doing
that yeah okay yeah we actually just got
back into the car - he said that right
he's on and I told him I when I first
heard about that a while ago I was like
what a great idea it was a great concert
and then once we started driving to LAX
to actually pick people's asses up from
there you took them to and away right or
it was it just a pig I could never
schedule it so that we got somebody on
the way and on that was like the dream
but we could we're too lazy and
disorganized to me that's a lot of I
mean it's a lot and I don't think we'd
have that much to say by the time by the
time that second part was there I'd be
like all right how did it go I mean I
wish that you did every episode there
and back because because by episode 12
on pick ups you'd be like pick you up at
departures now you have to you're so
tired you have to talk this is a podcast
yeah it's a total fighting yeah your
twitter twitter is caracal gary at at
karen code era for whatever and i think
that's all I'm on actually I quit
Facebook why did you I'm so jealous I
really on the border of it I really am
yeah I couldn't take it anymore there's
people yelling at me that I didn't know
who they were and I was like I I don't
understand I thought we had a I thought
we did know each other I you know I mean
I just thought your profile pic was
different I didn't know it was just you
and your Christian agenda though was
driving me insane the Lord but how and
how long you've been doing my favorite
murder we just recorded our 40th episode
all right yes and it's caught like
wildfire right we got go check
that out because it's telling you know
tell everybody what it is well it's just
my friend Georgia hardstark and I and we
just we read each other we're both into
true crime so we just read each other
our favorite murder or true crime event
whatever it is each week so the other
person doesn't know what what their go
the other one's going to read and it's
just basically like the this last
episode we did mine were the the my way
murders and the Philippines where
there's there's a there's been in the
past decade twelve different people who
have murdered other people while they
were singing my way at a karaoke bar oh
that's amazing the best and then like at
the same karaoke bar like who's up like
it's it's a tradition just a serial
killer waiting at a table no it's it's
like a combination of it's a popular
song that people sing badly and it's a
very violent country with a lot of
illegal guns and a lot of machismo and
so people get shit-faced
and then if somebody gets up and it's
like all Swagger is things my way it's
very often people end up like getting
into either knife fights or at one [ __ ]
this guy I'm singing Dokken get off
they're like because you can if you're
drunk enough like thank you the being
out of tune during my way it would
probably be insanely painful yeah so not
as painful that stabbing it to him
yeah took him tonight from Iowa yep is
that would that be the strangest one
then I mean that's pretty out there
it's super crazy I mean I really did
when my friend told me about it I wanted
it to be one guy killing all the does
well like it was like but they're
copycat murders exactly it's just like
oh yeah we hate this too but there's a
ton of weird ones there's a ton of like
stuff where as we're reading we're
either bumming out oh yeah I mean all
murder is weird it's very weird to take
a life yeah yes and the circumstances
where people rationalize it and have you
ever had have you ever come across an
accidental one where you really feel
sorry for both people like man that
just unfortunate or anything like that
um here let me ask you this question
I'll propose a situation it was someone
told me one time about a friend of a
friend that I guess their driver was the
top of a hill and it was winter and the
daughter and the moms and the pastor she
parked at the top of the hill and I
guess the emergency brake didn't work
and the mom was you know belted in the
car just drifted downhill hits a tree
and kills her right there in front of
her so what did I mean what that's an
accident but they have to charge
somebody with something do they or do
they not like what would happen in that
is that manslaughter versus a murder I
couldn't be a murder there's no motive
but is murdering but also is murder
intentional can can you be charged with
murder on it if it's truly an accident
no I mean I think I think that they
wouldn't investigate that it would be
like if there's no motion for
unfortunate and awful yeah that girl
didn't take out an insurance policy on
her mother before that huh like you lift
one Rock and it's like oh so is
everybody kind of evil like it is is
that in everybody well that yeah that's
like the age-old question is man
innately good or nearly bad we thought
it'd be fun we'd murder someone
well that's awesome and people can check
that out at feral audio it's on feral
and people are I think I think everybody
secretly like some true crime and murder
stories always for the most part it's
just fascinating so it's kind of like
giving people permission to act like
they're into it I think that's yeah it's
awesome
it's escapism a little bit too right
yeah totally yeah and you kind of like
you get to touch the danger but then go
back to your safe home yeah deal with it
that's awesome yeah um I mean you
brought so much here I really want to
get started cuz I'm excited to talk
about all this stuff let's can we start
with please you know the Cubs are in the
World Series right now so might be
fitting to talk about mister
of Bill Murray oh yes that'd be a good
idea he's I mean he's a national
treasure he did you see him address the
White House the other day
no he did like you know in the morning
briefing he was there and he's dressed
like he was accepting an award and he
was dressed up as you know with his Cubs
gear and they're like ask him out the
word award he's like well let me tell
you something up plenty of sticks we're
excited about the big game the Mark
Twain Award yeah yeah I heard about that
and I think I read something about it
I mean like he's just so people
worshipped that guy worship worship
worship Him and I myself included it's
like I was I think I was 12 when like
stripes was on HBO it's like that kind
of my at my age he was just like
everywhere in front of my face you know
and in that comedy sensitive comedy time
when I was growing up where I'm like I
want to be him but I actually got to
meet him one time which these days
everyone can now say because he shows up
at everyone's I mean you said it's not
everyone it seems to be happen more
frequently in all that he's he's making
it happen a lot but when when it
happened to me it wasn't like this trend
of him showing up everywhere all the
time so it was your the tipping point
yeah I feel like I was an early adapter
but what it was was I was at a bar I'm
fronting Garofalo and she lives in New
York and she is friends with them
because they they did I I think it was
operation Dumbo drop or one of those
movies to get one of his best like one
of those epic films to class and they've
been good friends for a long time so she
would do a thing where I was back there
visiting and just and doing sets and
stuff and she we would meet up at a bar
and she'd go oh I called some people and
then like a random array of people would
show up and every once in a while it
would be like a famous person and so
this time it was Bill Murray and we
started at like safe it was like five
o'clock and we were in this weird bar I
don't know what neighborhood we're and I
wish I did but it was the kind of bar
that during the day it was just a big
old almost like a cheers bar like but
the big rectangular bar in the center
and but there was also like roped off
areas that we just all went and sat in
because there was couches and we were
this big group of like 12 people and it
was like them it was the best space for
us but it was no one was in the bar so
there's no reason for us to be over
there just that it was more comfortable
guys just broke up yeah yeah thanks
we're gonna be in the couch area but
then as the night progressed more and
more people were there and Bill Murray
was in our group so then morn I think
probably even more people were showing
up then maybe I don't know it was one of
those everyone's texting so yeah yeah I
think probably that's what I would have
been doing and I was actually so we were
sitting kind of in a long C shape and I
was down at the bottom of the sea and he
was up at the top and see four Cubs and
so I was dying I was so nervous and I
kind of when I get nervous like I don't
like that many celebrities so when I
actually do I get this like I kind of
shut down a little bit and I almost got
like I just don't want to meet them I
that's not exciting to me because I feel
like there's it's only it loses the
mystique a little bit yeah and I feel
like it's gonna go bad like yeah I feel
like you can it's very easy to be
disappointed by like your heroes
I got disappointed one time by hero so I
totally get I'll tell you Michael
Richards oh yeah not okay well so I just
had that thing where was like it was
nerve-racking and I wasn't like I was
gonna go of me like mr. Marie or
whatever so we were just kind of sitting
down on our end and at one point I had
to go to the bathroom and so I stood up
to go to the restroom in this bar and I
it had gotten so crowded in this bar
that I couldn't walk back to the
bathroom like people wouldn't move I was
trying to like slide between people and
it was just like you I couldn't access
it mm-hmm
and so I came back and I leaned over to
Jeanine who was at the top part where
Bill Murray was and I was like hey I'm
gonna run down to that Starbucks down
the block and I'll be right back because
I can't get to the bathroom and Bill
Murray stands up and goes I'll take you
to the bathroom and he put his hand out
he knew you never said anything about he
just overheard that I was just gonna run
cuz I was just like you know and so he
makes this very grandiose gesture or
whatever and so I'm like okay and then I
have to take his hand and then he turns
and walks me through this crowd and of
course it parts and everyone is like
kind of looking up at him look like he
just walked that little place on to that
little like yeah dumb like you know he's
just kind of like not people and then so
they're looking at him and then they're
looking down at me like who the [ __ ] are
you that he's walking like the bar so we
walk all the way down this packed bar we
get to the restroom line and it's two
unisex bathrooms so there's all kinds of
people standing in a line of say eight
people and we get to the back of the
line and I wouldn't be kind of rest and
then I was just like really quick in my
head I was just like well here's your
moment to blow like yeah you're gonna
try to say something funny and it's not
gonna be funny and how embarrassing and
like right as we land it's like there's
like a beat and I was just gonna
whatever say like oh we made it or
whatever dumb thing and I turn and aim
like supermodel this girl was like 6
feet tall and was wearing the tiniest
dress and she dropped out of nowhere
like I didn't see her
hi I'm whoever and they just start
having a conversation so and then the
bet one bathroom door opens and I like
practically bolted in go into the
bathroom just like okay he's got her and
you just go in here to your business and
get out and go to that Starbucks cry so
I finish corny the bathroom and I come
out at this point I don't mean to
interrupt but at this point you never
you didn't get a chance to say anything
good or bad good or bad it was
supermodel hey arm against I wish you
had like that so awkward you like I
really
because I mean I can't even imagine I
know I get awkward sometimes around
people like that as well and you I just
never know what I'm gonna say and I have
that thing where I want to be I want so
badly to be like chill and calm that
then things come out of my mouth that I
am NOT I don't even know where they're
coming it's just always safest to use
manners yes exactly and just be like
thank you so much I didn't know if I was
gonna make it
that's it I gotta be honest bill I peed
when you took me so I get out of the
bathroom and I walk down this hall and I
come to the end of it and I'm standing
there waiting for him to be done and I
wait like 35 seconds and there are
people that are staring closely 35
minutes but I start thinking like
because there's people staring at me
like that's the girl that walked about
eight I mean he's the star of the bar
and then I start thinking okay he could
be in that bathroom with that supermodel
or he could be doing something else I
don't know I'm not sure how long ago he
went in he might be at the Starbucks
anything could be happening so why am i
standing here like weird dates at the
prom I just need to go back to my seat
I'm an idiot why why would I think that
he did stupid so and I'm like you're
reminding me bathroom but I guess not so
so I walk back and I'm like super
embarrassed because I think altogether I
waited four minutes for him or something
kind of standing there no nothing to
distract myself just like standing
waiting and then I was like oh my god
this is so embarrassing
so I get back to our net roped-off area
now was it a struggle again we oh yeah
upstream and it was like I don't got
black I'm in yeah I worked for it um but
I finally get better
he was not bad I knew it what do you do
with my friends at my end of the area
and I'm like oh my god you guys I have
to tell you this really quick so he
walked me at the bathroom and then I
waited but then I realized like how
stupid and whatever and I could have
sworn he would have come back by himself
and as I'm panicking and telling my
friends he walks you but he was kidding
yeah so you got Bill Murray to use you
as a joke yeah that's amazing it was all
it was all a gorgeous like Christmas
gift that was pretty good and I remember
at the time when I came back from that
trip I went to tell my friend the story
and I was like you're is another comic a
guy and I was like you're never gonna
believe this
I had this thing with Bill Murray and he
goes don't tell me and I was like what
he's like I don't tell me I'm here he
was so jealous Oh
tell the anecdote that's how much Bill
Murray means to all of us it's it's up
there yeah sure well I mean you hear so
many crazy stories were only eatin
people's french fries and you know when
people are yeah jogging through the you
know what I mean like weird stuff
showing up their wedding photos yeah
that's great I love that he does that I
love that he doesn't take a celebrity
too seriously I love that he still has
fun with people I mean and I used to do
the golf thing for a while and I know
that I feel like that was a little bit
of mixed bag some I know some of the
golfers didn't appreciate him out there
[ __ ] around and stuff I've heard
about you champion of golf game no oh
it's not so he's just messing I was like
the Bob Uecker of golf yeah he's not
like I don't think he's terrible but I
bet he's I mean he's definitely not
shooting eight he's I bet he shoots like
I bet he shoots in the high nineties as
my guess I know all I know is my dad's
super into golf and it really pisses him
off when Bill Murray doesn't see oh my
god well he only plays at pro-am
so it's like have them out there who
doesn't want to see Bill Maher I guess
some people don't I would do anything
people yeah I'm serious
yes at golf are you really oh yeah big
time oh yeah I love it and I would do
anything this I mean like I don't like
playing with guys that are horrible but
I will like with friends that aren't
great because you like oh you know when
you're going out with a friend who's
awesome and you can go out and you can
play match playing you can like really
like shape shots and talk off and then
you have days you go with your buddies
who are drinking fireball on the fourth
hole that great witch on the golf shot
or the fireball it starts good yeah I'm
just looking at your list here you you
we love a good ghost story and so do our
fans and listeners I mean go everyone
does right is something about being able
you know who didn't Steve Simone
remember he got up from the table
covered his ears and walked away he was
petrified you know he submerges himself
and his body's chilling and stuff like
that
well I listen to it you your guys most
recent episode
creepy I love that stories you think it
was so creepy have you that guy killed
hunter two days ago on the release you
gotta get get the murderer on we get him
how creepy that's the creepiest like
we've heard some really messed up
stories but as far as creepy goes that
is creepy when he was talking about like
the energy changing when the door opened
and like the cult like all of that were
like and you've been around people that
are that creepy and you know exactly
what that means
oh my I was freaking out yeah yeah I
love I like to get scared in general
like I used to go like I used to live in
Venice behind a bikini in between Venice
and Lincoln you knows all alleys yeah
and I was like and I was like 25 and I
used to like love to walk the alleys at
night because I wanted something to
happen you know I mean like yeah I
walked here tonight took an alley but
it's like you know was like 8 o'clock
but I would go like 2 o'clock in the
morning just like looking for something
to affect me
that'll happen in Venice that's amazing
nothing happened
I know but I wanted like you know I
wanted like ghosts sorry you don't get
to pick I don't get was big I was out
looking for these dudes beating a woman
one time and I lost yeah in her house in
her house there like it was hers oh well
in the house and it was a her she they
were going the door and the man hitting
her yeah and I was like I hid behind a
car and I'm call 9-1-1 and then they're
like looking over me and I [ __ ]
bailed yeah I mean I thought they did
you know what I mean yeah that's intense
yeah go some cool with though we used to
we used I also like to be scared in high
school we used to always do like a
weekend like a midnight adventure and we
would do a cemetery in Baltimore City
that would like two o'clock in the
morning which was just I mean we would
huddle together like the Scooby Doo kids
and just be all like big like like a
cell moving together it's cuz if one
person wrong afraid to be the last like
I cannot be once the panic like trigger
goes there was always one so we and then
we would find an old abandoned house and
we'd all just in the middle of a field
in the middle of nowhere we'd all walk
through the field up to and go in and
there was always one friend it was just
lag a step back and take a rock and
throw it hit that house and I mean we
would turn around and practically run
over he doesn't get the [ __ ] out who are
you did you drink or do anything a
little bit like I'm you talking about
you know you know a couple of beers but
mostly a hundred percent sober you know
really almost every time because when we
drive yeah and then the scariest one
though it was this old abandoned
hospital it was a I want to say it was a
tuberculosis Hospital way back when and
it just evey TB by and it was a ballad
yeah we call TV I wanted you to know my
I had a vocabulary and you know we would
take a flashlight in and you go down
floors and we would shine one there'll
be like someone would be a wheelchair
just facing you with it with a devil
sign on the wall we would and there were
there were toe tags still left no all
was creepy it was so creepy it's very
silly sorry we're just Maryland
okay we should do that stuff all the
time and if there was like a hell house
or whatever like that we would go we
would go like idiots we would go well I
have a friend my friend Cullen Crawford
was a security guard at an abandoned
hospital I think he he basically tweeted
one day of all the creepy things that
happened he was like the night shift
security guard and it was an abandoned
hospital that they were trying to keep
people out of until they redid it or
something and as he walked through like
one night the phone rang and it was he
had all these stories that were crazy
and he just tweeted them all like on a
Sunday afternoon one day super fun you
just reminded me that we didn't do your
shoutout oh it's not him I was gonna say
we didn't do your shoutout um do you
shut up cuz I want to come back to Colin
Crawford okay
I want my shout out to be my friend John
O'Connor on Twitter John T O'Connor Jo
HN Terminator that's his mother Sarah
Cohn
he's just hilarious he only has like
three thousand followers and he just
writes perfect perfectly crappy jokes
and I don't think he's a stand-up he
might be like a writer's assistant I
don't really know him that well I just
know him from Twitter but I love his
content perfect right he needs more
people all right yeah all right so back
to security guard the phone ring did he
answer him did he pick it up I think he
did I mean I'm the worst cuz he took he
told all these stories in his thread but
it was like [ __ ] that if you pick it up
would you burn her from behind I don't
know I wouldn't take that goddamn job
it's like one of those jobs where
they're like okay we'll pay you $15 an
hour cuz no one wants to do it in a band
in the hospital yeah and I'm certainly
not walking through it I'd walk around
it did he have a little I didn't want a
little Hut I wouldn't want a little
station I've seen too many movies - no
that's the first guy to go yeah and if
you you're there like days even then I
shot at an abandoned
mental hospital when I shot the artwork
for my first album and it was the day
and but we were in like the basement oh
and I would like we were shooting at the
end of the hall like that me like
leaning up against the hall this one I
was playing one character here and then
one here and it was right where the hall
split and went off the other way and
then behind was all dark and I remember
like I'd be shoot like he'd be shooting
he was down like end of the hall where
we had all of our gear in the other room
and I was like we got a weak guy because
I was like this is crazy
I mean it's it really is terrifying to
flick a flashlight on in a pitch-black
long hallway at the other end just see
oh just oh just a wheelchair facing it
it's terrifying
no that's terrif that's all you need
really just a clipboard or something or
just terrified horrifying well so you
have a ghost story but what I love is
you said I believe it's legit so I can't
wait to hear I know that this really
happened but it's the kind of thing
where as I set up the background of the
story I become an unreliable narrator
because I was in college and all we did
was drink all the time so it always
feels like yeah I have a ghost story and
people are like yeah yeah but then by
the end it's like well then you can pull
anything apart it's you know in that way
but I just I only say that to say I
assure you I know that this happened so
we lived in this house it was I went to
Sac State for Sacramento State
Sacramento State
interesting we were just up there sure
what's up Zach taps oh yeah
how about Arden shopping center that's
right that's exactly where I was right
there next to the mattress store yeah
that's right though so I I lived in
Sacramento for two years which is like
okay it was it was a we just drank all
the time like that's as much as we
possibly could so it was four girls
renting this house and there was two of
us shared the front room and my friend
Kristi had this back room and then my
friend patty was supposed to have the
Attic room but it was summer in
Sacramento so it was so hot and there
was no a/c up there it was literally
like almost 200 degrees in her room
every day so she always slept on the
couch
so this a one floor with an attic
exactly and it was kind of like this it
was probably from the 30s the house and
so it had like our room there was a
bathroom in between our room and the
hallway to the back room where Christy's
room was so it was our the bathroom door
opened onto our room and then you could
walk through the bathroom open that
other door open to the back hall it's
I'm going in a circle around our room
through the bathroom in the back hall
and through the front room essentially
is the point of all that just so you
know how this set up was so when an
anytime we would have people come and
stay at our house then next morning
after they spent the night maybe usually
sleep on the couch they would complain
about people doing the dishes in the
middle of the night and we never caught
on like we never we never added it up
that you didn't do miss Sarah that [ __ ]
she's leaving upstairs on the couch
every night so wait how many people
would you say said this to you four none
and did they know each other
no they and they stayed at different
things conspiracy like if I mean what
what did they know each other you would
do it like just tell her your dishes so
they all tell you they're all go and it
wasn't planed about it so they were like
why would you do something right like
you woke me up and I go I don't know
you're talking about and of course just
never think about it again that's how we
all kind of were and so drunk drunks
self-centered ludicrous drunks and I had
just flunked out of Saxon sup girl me
too
yeah got back in did you really yeah
year later my parents called me on the
phone and we're like we love you you
know we think you're great but you don't
get to have any more money so I had
basically just signed a lease on this
house and flunked out and then was like
high and dry had no idea I was gonna pay
the next month's rent cuz I didn't have
a job
yeah I was totally spoiled and
privileged on whatever end was my
parents were like goodbye
so I was definitely mom I'm doing dishes
every night you wouldn't believe what
I'm doing up here drinking and Keystone
Light across the street we fake ID that
my friend found at the gym and it was a
girl named jail bora and she was so tiny
and looked nothing like any of the girls
that lived in this house you know it's
crazy she's still little she was like
she in this picture she looked like one
of those girls that every girl's it used
to burn that eyeliner so that it would
be melty when they put it on did you
have any girls like that I mean maybe
but I wasn't like with that goth look
you it was kind of more like stoner girl
like this thing that the look comes off
yeah like a little bit of an Egyptian
wing I saw that out here for the first
time I don't remember seeing that a much
in Maryland at least in Sacramento it's
like it was kind of like the thing where
they sometime to do the inside line it's
just like hard hardcore girls that was
jail Boras picture and we would take it
like I would take it over there and be
like her street you know give me all my
beers and we would we were all 18 we
would fill the house with beer and just
be drunk all the time so anyway so one
morning I wake up from a terrible dream
and it was really strange because it
wasn't scary in and of itself but in the
dream i hear someone at the front door
of the house oh man I get up out of the
bed I walk to the front door of the
house I pull the dream within the dream
yes exactly where that dream a lot
totally real and I pull back the curtain
of the front door this is like an old
freshman front door with the window on
the top and I see that there's a mother
and daughter standing on our front porch
and the mother is saying to the daughter
it's okay we're just gonna stand here
for a second and he'll go
oh my god I just got chills down my
whole back oh so that's the dream
did they knock did you say they knocked
no they don't
I heard some heard them in the dream i
hear him from my room and so I go in
check and I see that it's the mother and
I see a little girl with braids and they
have a suitcase and they mother was a
coat on so anyway I think from this like
are they current no they do not look
current but and if I had to guess I
would say forties or fifties but I'm not
sure and then you said the house was
probably around the 30s 30s for sure if
not earlier
well it's getting crazier so so I wake
up from this dream really upset and I
don't know why because technically
nothing happened in the dreams two
people on the front porch nothing and
I'm like really shaken and I feel super
weird and I open the door to my room
that opens onto the front room and Patti
is sleeping on the couch and when I open
the door it wakes her up and she goes oh
god like that and I go are you okay and
she was I just had the worst dream
oh no I go was it about a mother and
daughter standing on our front porch and
she starts crying oh I have goose bumps
down my leg we had the same dream same
time yeah so she got a little more of it
than you did see she got like five
seconds you got just a touch more my
daughter is the best dishes go away
her name is Jail I wonder if house you
gotta ask her if she saw him and that's
why when she got scared she when you
woke her up she you just woke up upset
yeah the noise you made when you open
that door she screamed out like almost
like made a disturbed noise yes I wonder
if she saw him I do too well hold on a
sec it was was it definitely a disturbed
noise I just wanna make sure rice that
was a disturbed noisy one
for the record I try to make sure I have
it right here just a disturbed person
wait you still talk to her you still in
correspondence we got is right now I
will do that that's so funny that I it
that's such a great reflection of the
mindset I had where it's just like oh
that was weird
so anyway and they just threw it out
nonchalant like that you like was it
about this [ __ ] right there was no way I
thought that's what it was like I was
making a joke like oh what's the problem
yeah so did that freak you out yes okay
good one also she was not like a
hysteric in any way so and she was like
oh boy [ __ ] did you say that she was
like very upset so then that like that
dies down we cracked some 3:30 in the
morning your adrenaline say this I don't
know what day of the week this was but
we'll say it's a Tuesday well say it's a
Tuesday that weekend everybody leaves to
go home for the weekend but me I'm on my
own I'm the yeah I'm the young rebel
that decided to throw her career away so
everyone's like biased see you later I
didn't even think about it so and I'd
also been reading Silence of the Lambs
oh so that night I go to bed also I will
just say this my sister Laura also went
away to college when I did she went to
the JC for two years and then I graduate
and we both moved to Sacramento together
but she lived on the other side of town
with all of her friends and so I go to
bed and she was home that weekend with
your parents so I go to I read that all
day or whatever I go to bed but wait I
gotta ask you I'm sorry you guys weren't
like telling everyone in the house like
oh my god this happened you weren't just
tripping off that no like I'm going to
be repeating this story to people now
when I hear I mean this this is crazy oh
my god so it was super weird because I
think also we were all like we're
theater kids and we if there was like a
level of narcissism
that was amazing so everyone was all
like in their own [ __ ] all the time so
even if we told that story I'm sure the
person we told it to was like yeah
anyway can I have your mascara it was
always that so so anyway I go to bed
late and I'm in my bed and I am sleeping
facing the wall and my with my back to
the rest of the room and my bed is very
vulnerable my bed is in the corner of
the room that like the head of the bed
is that shares the same wall as that
bathroom door that I so much needed to
explain to you so I wake up in the
middle of the night because I hear
walking in the house is a wood floors
yes and it's so it's a squeak and a
thing and wait and that sound and I'm
laying there and I I was in like this
position like my hands under my head and
it kind of balled up and I'm like now it
can't be what it is and then I hear it
again and then I hear it again and is it
like slowly doing one at a time like
step yeah
pause step but are you thinking intruder
are you thinking yes immediately I think
I can't believe this is the way I died I
like I can't believe it
I I was already there I was just like
this is shocking when and I was really
like all my muscles were really tight
and your it must it would take
everything in your world to just roll
over oh yeah no that that was not you
were just gonna day that lay there and I
deserve it just use your fake ID I
didn't get into school ask me in the bag
I flunked out but but the thing was I
kept saying like this can't be happening
so then I would hear another step and it
would be like no and then then I hear
the the other bathroom door open and I'm
like you gotta be [ __ ] kidding me now
you think there's to know the mom and
the girl I'm still wouldn't be thinking
ghosts yet I would be thinking two
intruders I
I was thinking intruder but so what
you're saying is he he or she or
whatever went around and opened that
door yeah same person walking in the
house not in my room so it was basically
like in in the say kitchen or in the you
know living room whatever I heard
footsteps and I was like no there's no
[ __ ] way and then it was like then
they went down that hallway and I was
still like this can't really be
happening then the bathroom door opens
then I hear a footstep on the linoleum
what 1 2 3 and then I hear my don't know
so then I am and did it open it did it
well but but I'm facing the wall so at
the bat I hear that door open and then
I'm I am like freezing cold and hot at
the same time like me right now yeah
yeah and super tense and then I hear
step on the carpet step on the carpet oh
I feel no wait I'm like a tense ball of
muscle and my body tips back a little
bit with the weight of this sitting on
the bulb
I just asked I that one arm goes around
the bottom of me one arm comes around
here and then it's hugging hugging
hugging hugging hugging
super tight and I go oh and then it's
just over nuts so I'm still just a
little girl thanking you I think a mom I
think the mom little girl came into that
house and whoever lived there killed
them that's what I think happened I
think the I think there was a man the
continuation of that dream was they get
they come in the house and then that man
that will go away killed him
I think the person in the house made
them think they were safe in there like
they could spend the night in there or
something killing them in that room
maybe all I can want to answer them one
in your room I mean I called my sister
at 3 in the morning and I was like you
have to come and get me why do you think
it was I think I think it was the killer
or do you think it was that hugged me
yes yes I think that
I was probably in the room where the
either I don't know it feels like it
would be the little girl because it was
these arms were really strong and it was
like a crushing sensation like all the
air went out of my body I mean I would
be in therapy immediately after this did
you stay living in that house yes we but
we only we moved out like I would say
six months later six months yeah I
couldn't even do six days I couldn't do
it by myself like my sister was so
pissed when she came to pick me up
because it was the middle of the night
she's like you woke everybody and I was
like you don't understand what just
happened to me but it was that kind of
thing what was like I tell her and then
she's like anyway it's my clunky sister
seriously like I didn't even sleep alone
and then I you know like I told my
roommates but they're all like oh really
so that that was probably just a crazy
dream like anyone I would tell it was
that thing of like that didn't really
happen yeah we do the crazy girl who
flunked out of school
[ __ ] back Keystone's every chance she
gets all right kid you remember the
address um I don't know I I know that it
was a number Street off of Folsom and it
was the first house the first building
on the street was this weird bakery this
brick building yeah and then the next
house over was our house anyone lives up
there in Sacramento off the Folsom
number Street 43rd I think was 40 up the
damn house yeah we can see like if there
was a murder there I already tried to
lure accidental death I tried to look up
have you talked about this on your
podcast
no this is should be one of your
favorite murders I like my ending I put
that address into Google to see and then
like put crime and stuff and nothing
came up what if this happened what if
the mother and daughter the the husband
was physically abusive and they left and
then what did she say at the door she
said we can wait here for a second he'll
go away all right so they wait for a
second maybe they she just stabbed him
to death
and then he was like me
crawl allows maybe they killed him or
maybe he did go away and because you
scared him away and they that little
girl came in and hugged you
oh but that little girl thank you huge
arms it's a lot of years later she was
thirty you know what [ __ ] 70 years on
that man it was that isn't crazy my
[ __ ] a matter of people not to be just
Slough that off look I just say this if
I had that story and I was going on a
storytelling podcast I would come in
here like a [ __ ] firework show dude
wait till I tell you what I see just
waltz didn't do it slowly and then she's
like yeah I had this nightmare like wow
that's crazy
oh yeah well hold on a sec and then hold
the bed sits up and gets [ __ ]
squeezed yeah [ __ ] man I think I come
out it I don't think people believe me
and I don't I'm not all that interested
in like trying to make people believe me
because I don't trying to make anyone
believe anything right but it really
happened and also holy Lord paddy Reilly
will will testify at least to the [ __ ]
tellin everybody round the way grabbed
her around a witness now listen we all
know camera fake IDs we didn't care
killin it in Sacramento okay so you say
obviously you drank a lot you told us
you have a drunk tattoo was that did you
get it during college no sadly I got it
two weeks ago oh really recently it was
but it was when I was still drinking so
I guess I was 27 at the time and I had
these friends please so you really were
Karen Keystone yeah I really was I was
Karen Keystone from aged like 14 til 27
oh you are a core hardcore team I it was
like I had something to prove
maybe I did that that ghosts are real
I was drinking to prove the ghosts are
real but um so basically my friend and
lived in my apartment building she lived
two floors above me where is this uh
Grace Avenue in LA yeah and she was the
bartender at the bar wheeze to go to
every night Fellini's which is insanity
they would lock the door to and we'd all
stay there to like Sun up and it we did
it constantly and it was really it was
insane so this one night we're all
hanging out and both of these girls were
tattoo girls like they were kind of like
riot girl style girls but I think they
were both from Chicago they were just
like kind of hardcore Suicide Girls a
little Suicide Girls II look like not as
you know less porn and more kind of like
hair products you know but still like
the map the girls at the Mac account
every time so we all got drunk together
one night and then just they just we
decided we were gonna get the words
Pogue Mahone tattooed on our butts which
is Gaelic for kiss my ass it's like
thing we're like drunk Irish girls they
be able to know they're Irish it's a
very like common kind of like how many
people you visually gonna let know that
I mean grandma [ __ ] yeah it was it was
not a good idea to start with and then
the funniest thing is that so we go
we're shit-faced we go to it's one of
those I don't even know if it's there
anymore to tattoo parlor on Sunset and
we get in there and we tell the guy we
want poke Mahone written on our asses
and he goes I won't do it and we're like
wait what and he's like no it'll I'll
have to make it too big
you can't do it like small it's gonna
have to be like this you'll you'll end
up looking like bikers like that's crazy
pick something else
and so my to tattoo friends were like oh
okay and they immediately have choices
of like oh I was also thinking of it you
know whatever Celtic Cross or I don't
know and yeah Irish whatever Irish they
wanted but I totally shit-faced had no
idea what's a good leprechaun drinking
at Keystone so I in my weird panic where
I was like I had never had any tattoos I
was the girl that like I wanted to be
goth in high school but I didn't want to
commit so I would dye my hair Auburn
instead of black it's like a very
specific kind of I couldn't commit to
black and being like full goth but I'd
be like what if I had a tint then you
knew that I would dye my really lames
gateway gateway exactly I was I was
willing to walk up to the gate and like
touch it that should be your book
gateway to go next chapter Egyptian I
turns out we never get there so I in a
drunken like panic start looking through
the book that's on the counter so
instead of finding a tattoo artist that
will do this right you decide all right
I'm gonna let that guy dictate the thing
I'm gonna put on my body for just being
like nevermind [ __ ] yeah maybe I
dodged a bullet I I don't see that
obviously I've been given an out and
also this is a person who works at a
tattoo place on Sunset so there's people
going in there they're like yeah can I
get a leopard eating my wife out he's
like sure blonde or brunette and then
get this phrase and he's like go [ __ ]
yourself so my tattoo friends are
already in they're getting theirs and
like we had it the whole idea was like
we have to do it together
so I'm like flipping through the book
and a panic is everyone getting the same
one to that yes the two of them were
getting celtic crosses I'm pretty sure
and like on their ass
no they switched the Celtic Cross was
filling up her calf it was huge and I
think Anne was getting the same thing
but getting it like on her bikini line
or something and I was like I'm not
getting that and so I had remembered
that we were looking at some book of
like of like Gaelic folktales or
something and there was there was one
about a fish Fintan the salmon of
knowledge and if you caught him
Bentham fintan the salmon of knowledge
and all I get it down to the nose if you
catch him and eat of him you will have
the wisdom of the ages so I was like
this is Hilaire in my drunken thinking I
was like this is hilarious and brilliant
so I'm gonna get a salmon I'm gonna get
a tattoo of a salmon not just any salmon
Fenton Fenton guy was like I can't do
that I can do a Hal but in the book
that's on the counter it's just
basically like it looks like the the
Field & Stream version of the salmon it
looks like the sticker on the back of
the fisherman's truck guys yeah yeah
just the one that's jumping on the trout
the one we all know well that was that's
the one so that's what I got and I have
it on my lower back like it's like a
[ __ ] stamp but it's out there it's like
that bits big it's like that big and it
was this weird like this [ __ ]
attitude I had but about a tattoo it's
not like I think you had that attitude
towards life I really yeah I really have
needed to teach myself these lessons in
in a permanent way so it's like in it
now I used to work with you probably
know Margaret Smith I used to work with
her and when we would have to go
upstairs she was behind me on the stairs
sometimes my shirt would come up she
would see part of it she go we're gonna
take up a collection and get that thing
filled in I can help you with that
why is it only the boy you just were
like stop and you know I didn't really
want it and like I certainly wasn't
gonna have him like you know color it in
and fill it in so that I had like
a Field & Stream salmon on like like
what I don't even care about fishing I
don't think things you get a removed I
think that's exactly what you get you
should get like a dude with like a big
gut fish and smoke but like a visor on
catching it catching it yeah remember
that old there's like a old cartoon
t-shirt and it's like the guys like I
love fishing but it the the fish are
sucking is yeah he's got a dick out yeah
because the shirt comes down to over
that's tight yeah just I'm saying maybe
I could make it even funnier than it
already is and it was the kind of thing
where I got it
I was excited for like three days and
every time I'd be like do you want to
see my tattoo people would be like oh
yeah and then they would look at it and
they go oh like no one has ever had a
positive reaction or been able to fake a
positive reaction to it yeah that stuff
and that's the only tattoo you've ever
had yeah I see you said that's when you
were drinking so did you you've stopped
yes altogether not just the drink here
and there no no yeah I stopped in 1997
damn that's when I heard Keystone stock
went down exactly luckily for me why did
you stop what you did you get carried
away what are you comfortable talking
people shoulders no I actually started
having seizures at night at first I
didn't know a host Yeah right
possessed it's a possession people like
man she can dance the longest most
drawn-out possession in the world what
that doesn't bother me that much so I
would have these dreams that I was a
like a spinner dolphin or more like a
salmon it's it's my past it's um amazing
if that was like the secret theme of my
life yeah you're a water sign okay
Mordor yeah tell us
um anyway so so what do you mean you
started heavens tell me do you remember
the first time you had one yeah
so my and how do you know if you're
sleeping how do you know well the the
the first waking symptom that I had was
I was putting on mascara in the bathroom
chips not right I was burning my
eyeliner in the bathroom and I was
looking forward and all of a sudden my
eyes were looking up like this to the
left but I wasn't doing it they were
they were like on their own looking up
to the left and they did that like five
times and then I just was like anyway
and just kept putting on distracted by
them that I can't yeah super freaky and
I just was like I don't know what that
just was but I can't and again ignoring
it yes ignoring my specialty I didn't
realize how much until I came here today
um so then the next one then I was
having these dreams wait next one same
night or that was all that happened that
night that first don't happen that first
time was just I started noticing my eyes
were doing weird things without me so
then I was having dreams I was waking up
on the floor sometimes and I was
oftentimes like a dead fish was this was
this after the ghost happened yes oh
ten years later yeah took him a while to
find all the way down the five oh that
poor ghost had to hitchhike so what so
basically one morning I would wake up
and my tongue would be really bit and I
was like what am i doing whatever and it
would just be or I'd have like blood in
the corners of my mouth and I just
thought oh I'm grinding my teeth so bad
that I'm biting my tongue so one but I
know that like these things are kind of
happening and that's not good and the
eye thing was really weird it would
happen like when I was driving down
I it would feel like I was looking
checking the other cars but really it
was just my eyes doing that flick but I
looked to me it felt like I was just
looking over to the other lane a bunch
of times so anyway I woke up one morning
and my tongue was so bit and I could
barely talk and my my friend called me
and so I was like sorry I can't it's
weird I can't talk that good my tongue
is so bitten and I turn around and look
where my bed is and there's just a
splash of blood on the wall it was it
looks it looked like this you know like
this scenic department came in to make
us scary yeah thing over my bed and it
was just like it basically looked like
three big spurts of blood were on the
white wall and I just whatever my friend
was saying I just let her keep telling
me this story and I just went over and
got a sponge and like wiped it off and
just how do you put that filter off or
[ __ ] like I would be like oh my god like
I know I have had I've had more than a
handful of time I've had nightmares that
have woken me up and I've got a knot on
my tongue and it's bleeding badly even
the dentist is like let me see that
that's scar tissue I'm like I [ __ ]
I've had nightmares a couple times where
it makes me jump so hard I snapped down
yeah yeah but never anything like that I
mean my god well so so what do you think
happened you bit your tongue so hard it
shot out yes because I was having
seizures I didn't know it but I was I
was having my seizures and at night
during while I was sleeping so that I
can so I can
see that's why I asked you how you knew
because I have a friend who's had she
had one seizure her whole life and when
she came to the paramedics were like you
know you just had a seizure and she's
like don't listen to my mom they're like
no you you really did get the seizures
my mom was like no no yeah a seizure we
were here you know so well it is such a
weird thing because you it's like losing
time it isn't I mean I knew I knew it
was happening when it started so
basically that happened and then the
next one I knew is the only reason I
knew about it is because my friend was
staying with me it was a terrible tiny
studio apartment she was staying on my
couch and I got home one night she was
already asleep on the couch I got into
bed and I was like waiting to go to
sleep and I felt my eyes doing that
looking to the left thing again only
they weren't stopping and it was really
strong and I like my head was turning
and I could feel it was repetitive and I
just thought in my head I thought this
is bad
don't fight it because Noor this push it
down but I basically just like relaxed
and then had a grand mal seizure and the
girl that was staying in my apartment
heard she thought I was choking and so
she got up and I was on the floor and my
lips were blue and my eyes were well no
whole thing so from that one the so
basically it was it was great that she
was staying with me because I finally
there was finally someone there to see
what was happening cuz that's what was
happening she call your sister mom dad
I'm coming home this weekend you guys
you have to let me this time
I woke up in a Dodgers t-shirt and
nothing else with three of the hottest
paramedics on the force they were a
force of nature I think or maybe they
were firemen I'm not sure I gotta say
I've had the Santa Monica Fire
Department have to come to my place and
they were checking on Donna's mom they
were all in shape good-looking dudes
yeah they really were where I grew up
they were volunteer firemen are like 300
[ __ ] pounds
these dudes are like they're training
they're in shape young good-looking guy
it seems like these days they're like
I'm ready for the calendar like they
know that there's also the best of the
bet I mean where else would you want to
be but yeah Santa Monica California you
know it's like you know the Marina del
Rey the one that's right on the on the
bay right there yeah on the marina girls
rollerskating by looking at the into the
fire department so yeah they're sitting
on my bed with me and the one like one
one climb behind you and the one guy
goes hey do you know your name and I was
like it's Karen okay you know do you
know what he said do you know what day
it is and I was like is it hot fireman
day I'm sitting in my bed in a t-shirt
and nothing else like and you know I'm
sure I'd like blood coming down my face
and I look like a total [ __ ] mess but
it was so embarrassing that I was just
like I can't be this girl right now
they kind of her like mmm but I think
was just very sad it was you know that
hideous studio apartment and everything
and so yeah I had to go to the hospital
and it turned out that the doctor but
this was my favorite the doctor looked
exactly like dick Van Patten like
exactly a neurologist that at this at
the county hospital that I had to go to
cuz I didn't have insurance of course
and when he said how many drinks do you
have a week I was like trying to do the
math in my head and I was like sitting
there like fine how many drinks you have
a night and I go you know 12 or and he
goes what yeah
oh no I said a night and I go yeah a
night and then you were really putting a
12-pack a night away you could do yeah
really yeah he's done no no no I wasn't
like totally brand loyal I wouldn't but
it was bad was there or just alcohol
near the end it was only whiskey mmm so
it yeah definitely progressed to bad
constant drinking Wow
but he was I was shocked at how shocked
he was and then I started realized oh I
don't have a normal life like I'm a
comic that is in a club every single
night
and all my friends drink so everybody's
getting drunk and I just think
everyone's doing what I'm doing and none
of none of no doctors are doing anything
we're doing so like he's like horrified
yeah
and once now that it's isolated and I
have to say it out loud by myself it's
like oh yeah that is actually not good
at all so I stopped so did you have to
take medication or anything or was it
just like as soon as you can stop the
booze it was all gone no I still have to
take medication because if I don't I
will have a seizure
to this day Wow but did the drinking
caused this or was this something that
happened and drinking just made it worse
they don't know like they can't really
pinpoint when it comes to neurological
stuff like that unless they like you
know it's they look into your brain with
surgery but they think I think
personally I was on diet pills in the
mid 90s to lose I lost weight really
fast on fen-phen that was the one yeah
that was the bad one real bad it's
really bad so was it causing seizures
and other people have you ever
researched it I've never heard about
seizures because I'm not any bother
looking [ __ ] my waist was like this they
it's supposed to have caused a lot of
heart problems and people had heart
attacks but yeah I don't know so but I
just figured that the the amount I drank
and had being on those diet pills I'm
pretty sure somehow gave me damage or
caused it in some way yeah yeah well
tilt I mean I'm glad you got to figure
it out I know me too
it also just that kind of drinking like
we that we did back then I just you none
of us would have survived
oh you can't your body can't keep up
with that no and then the we I did I
drunk drunk drove all the time like very
irresponsible really like not smart took
so many risks like that so yeah I feel
like I mean I just feel like everything
nowadays everything is heightened and
we're
exposed to or made aware more of things
and there's no excuse like I've had
plenty of friends and I'd say five years
ago or like three years ago that were
like F be at our house and then be like
alright we're taking off I'm like
alright so wait how are you getting home
yeah and I'm gonna drive I'm like why
just leave the car and take an uber yeah
I mean you do Bruce here now man just
take it really you think I'm fine I'm
like I know you're saying you're fine
but legally you're not fine
and if some families come from vacation
right and they get home late and the
ball rolls out of the caravan the kid
goes running after it is 12 o'clock
that's like a minivan that's what I mean
yeah and you know I mean it's like
because you yeah I know you're fine but
legally you know people don't get after
glass of wine and a half you're legally
drunk yeah well you you may you may be
able to drive a car home fine but if you
get pulled over you will you will fail
the test yeah that's not a drop legal
that's right like that ad buzzed driving
is drunk
that's right which is like they you're
right both driving is kind of fun it's
the best I can't even read that sign
after that I was gonna I was like that
too uh but I mean I shouldn't I take
that back I was not like that to I would
I would be at a club you know and then
I'm like man I've had three beers four
beers and now I'm gonna drive home in an
hour like hmm that's not smart and I
just I saw so many comedians
specifically get duis and fortunately no
one got hurt but I've seen so many and
and you know I know people who've been
in accidents killed by drunk drivers and
I'm just like man it's not a five
hundred dollar cab ride or uber it's
worth it it's work I mean when you think
about that end of it where it's like you
could kill somebody because you're too
proud to to perfect driver so far I want
the convenience of having the moment you
start arguing you're too [ __ ] drunk
exactly right exactly right we actually
at that time the worst night I ever
drove drunk I drove home I dropped
people off so I was like it was as if I
was a designated driver except for I was
definitely the drunkest one
it was insanity and I when I dropped off
my last friend from that apartment to my
house I had to drive with one hand over
one I could hold the keys down the
inside of the can was lined it tastes so
good but anyway when I got home I pulled
in the driveway owners like this is a
miracle that I got here basically I get
out of my car and my roommate is coming
out of the house and this is like you
know it's 3:30 in the morning it's
coming out of the house with the phone
with a cordless phone and and I get onto
the phone my friend Dave who was with us
and had passed out at the bar and passed
out in a booth we left him there they
locked him in a bunk he sat up when he
woke up he set off the alarm so he's
calling me from inside this wall alarms
go all the alarms going off going you
[ __ ] left me here you have to come
and get me and I go Dave I barely got
myself home and then I just handed her
the phone back and went in and passed
out in my room oh my god how'd he get
home
he they they the bartender's that we
were friends with when the alarm went
off they came back I get one more
Jagermeister shot for the road yeah it
was so ugly and of course he didn't talk
to me for like five days I was like I'm
so sorry I there was no way I was gonna
be able to drive back to that bar but he
was so mad that we forgot him and I was
like you passed out like at like say
1:30 like you were sleeping in a booth
and everyone continued to just get so
shit-faced like that you know bets are
off no one's taken care about people are
still drinking almost not I would
probably say none so you were just an
alcoholic you were hanging with
alcoholics we were yeah that's the worst
that's what everybody was like enabling
everybody else like it
this is so bad I love it you love it too
we've got to keep doing it yeah yeah I
only have one friend that like a really
close friend that was an alcoholic and I
remember like I had like three
heart-to-hearts with him like dude you
got to do something man you have to
figure something out man I'm like you
know it got so bad that we left him one
night I took his car I'm like you're
done you're done I'm taking your car I'm
going home I'm not staying out and the
next day he called me and he had gone
somewhere else with someone else and
then you just start linking up with
people you don't even know and he fell
off a wall and bash his face in his head
yeah and it is I in his I go to his
house and his girlfriend's Brazilian and
she and he's like you think I need a
hospital like yeah dude look at your
face oh they called me that night and
said he needs to the hospital and I had
his car and I was like I don't care I'm
like I'm not coming over I'll see you in
the morning
and one room oh yeah but it took like it
took like four or five of those kind of
nights before he finally was like oh
yeah I think I need to stop yeah I mean
when you're a real alcoholic like I
remember having the thought in my head
of like I'm never gonna stop doing this
like I don't care there was a this
insane defiance of like I get to do what
I want or whatever and so it really did
take that was the demon that was the
yeah I'll call demon that was the demon
that was hugged in but then yeah then it
then it actually the thing that it took
actually happens and then it's like all
right well at least I'm alive yeah
Ceaser's can do you mind
yep time to tell us one more story of
course um you you have I mean it's that
is the creepiest story of her but then
you have this masked jogger that I
thought I want to say I just want you to
tell the story because this looks extra
creepy too this is um this was like just
a fun recent creeped out that I had his
recent this is recent I was in my car I
was making a left off western onto
Franklin here in Los Angeles
looking right eyes darting everywhere
but up the hill it's like that part of
Western and then it goes uphill toward
Griffith Park yeah and you've been right
there and the little bear statues right
there
so I make and that left turn sucks
because those cars are coming down at
like 75 miles an hour and so you have to
like gauge it and whatever so as I'm
sitting there watching all the traffic
go by I see kind of up the hill a little
bit there's a jogger and he's not
wearing a shirt which is like my kind of
pet peeve but also like it's my kind of
my favorite thing like these people in
Los Angeles that are so beautiful they
just have to like put themselves on
display at all time that way with people
driving shirtless
oh yeah just in your car shirtless
rolling around yeah yeah
rolling around not convertible top and
stuff and they're kind of always like
tanning salon style there's an element
of cheese a base it's not like it's uh
there's no Friday Night Lights realness
to it it's kind of like you definitely
know they're an actor yeah so anyway
that's what I was firemen or fire or the
hot hot fire I see this guy coming down
and he's like dolphin shorts no shirt
you know do you were is the entities in
shape perfect shape gorgeously tanned
skin baseball hat and then as he jogs
closer and closer I see he's also
wearing a black nylon mask with no eye
and mouth holes and this is the middle
of the day in the middle of the day
coming down Western and I was like you
got pantyhose but perfectly black no fit
you can't see the face at all there's no
holes so it's oh it just looks like a
black spot of a head is jogging dead
with a hat with a hat with hat do you
remember the Hat the Hat was matched the
shorts also blue like well color wise it
was Dan Marino it was definitely a
jogging outfit but then the mask was
like it looked like something where
they're like okay
you know we did Human Centipede now what
are we gonna think of to freak the [ __ ]
out of people like it was that feeling
where you're like it doesn't add up
is it in my brain have I lost it again I
just scream - [ __ ] the blue man so yeah
he comes down and then I'm looking
around to see Kenan is anybody else
seeing this like because everything is
going as normal and this looks like it
has its own soundtrack of like scary
music to it so as soon as I possibly can
I tweet I just I was just at you know
the exact thing that happened I was just
at Franklin and Western and I saw a guy
jogging with no shirt tiny shorts and a
black nylon mask with no face or aisles
I mean Malheur aisles and a bunch of
people to you know laugh or talk about
it whatever and then the next morning I
get a tweet response and the avatar I
look and it's a naked guy he was in
taking a picture of himself in his
mirror from the chin down and down to
the top of what my friend Matt called
the dick neck I didn't know that was the
top like it was way too low he was
totally naked and he was like basically
giving you a little sample a Costco
sample at the top it's not a Twitter
thing that's not what a lot of people on
Twitter do I would say Early's not the
what I know I better like naked men I
know I'm not that's not for Twitter no
no you take that over to Instagram
that's over or on what tinder and all
those yeah yeah that's really a grind
but so here here is on on Twitter and
he's responding to mine it's him and he
says yeah what's up with that baseball
hat is his response and it's like 6:30
in the morning yeah and I was like holy
[ __ ] so I write back having followed
together not that many it was a couple
hundred I think I write back hi masked
jogger and then he immediately
it's back hi Karen Kildare no and it was
him
oh man it was like that oh I was him I
would have said I forgot creepy on he
had been following you on Twitter
already no I I think how did that even
get I don't know I think maybe someone
who knew his you staple in the community
or something I think it was a celebrity
there used to be the Silver Lake jogger
he passed away but he was the Silver
Lake jogger but he wasn't creepy I mean
just some old dude - had leather skin
that would jog shirtless out there and
he would he would read the newspaper as
he walks right my friend called
Silverlake Walker but he walked very
fast yes and my friend calls him dr.
Reid Walker or dr. Walker Reid that's
right read the paper a lot that's why I
meant by step on the gear yeah they're
trying to replace the Silverlake Walker
with the face the mass mass jogger
yeah but then someone told me that the
people jog with those masks for high
altitude running they're like training
their bodies yeah like that marathoners
yeah which is totally makes it
uninteresting to me and like I liked it
when is scary and weird maybe he was a
demon we still don't know that was a
high-altitude I mean that's a [ __ ] of a
hill tired and foul but it's now higher
than anything else well we're at that
time this flew by this is so fun this
was so much fun thanks so much for your
fantastic thanks for letting me dump all
my deepest worst problems you have got a
couple of things you legit gave me
goosebumps multiple times but you have
to ask you what was her name again paddy
Reilly you have to ask paddy Reilly if
what the extension of that dream was
okay well good offer Doug you know that
ball over to God there Wow oh yeah
you heard about that right well you want
more time promote your podcast what
anything you'd like please uh podcasts
are do you need a ride with Chris
Fairbanks on the all things comedy
network my favorite murder on feral
audio with Georgia hardstark
and then just Twitter I'm just on
Twitter which is Karen Cole Gareth at
caring clear awesome alright that was so
much fun thanks so much you guys are so
excited to come as always Jay Larson
calm be calm Jay Larson comedy on
Facebook Twitter Instagram and Pinterest
Ryan Sickler calm Ryan Sickler all
social media we'll talk to y'all next
Tuesday